ellie's kind of nationally getting a bad
rap right now obviously the homeless
shit's happening but
every every week we see a new video
someone getting robbed on melrose or
you know
wherever people there's a lot of [ __ ] i
mean you saw at fox hills mall they uh
they just did that snatch at the the
smash and grab yesterday
that's why i feel like the gun laws is
[ __ ] out here because it's like
well we got to protect ourselves like if
i mean like even like walking around
with this much jewelry on and [ __ ] like
this like
it's almost like you'll risk the
whatever consequences that come with
having a gun illegally so yeah because
you'd rather have it then i got friends
i got i literally got like you know
wealthy friends right
who won't even just they don't they
don't even go outside with no jerry they
go outside on some real regular [ __ ]
nowadays just because of that type of
[ __ ] you feel me
yeah like
but it's it's that lay bro like
our our [ __ ] don't stop our [ __ ]
ain't gonna never stop bro like what do
you think it was because because do you
because edd was bigger here probably
than anywhere else yeah so all that [ __ ]
left yup you fell off saying and they
see who still got it left
and they gonna leave them with nothing
because once you get that that edd bread
was crazy
that was the beauty of 2020 that was a
moment
there's gonna be a documentary on
netflix in like five years i dropped my
own
dude
what
i'm like bruh there's no that would that
was like like some
like some unreal [ __ ] like i've i've
seen people with money who never had
i've seen people who never had
five thousand dollars they jumped from a
twenty dollar bill to twenty thousand
dollars